we have already introduced the concept
of the conditional pmf of a random
variable X given an event a we will now
consider the case where we condition on
the value of another random variable Y
that is we let a be the event that some
other random variable Y takes on a
specific value little Y in this case we
are talking about the conditional
probability of the form shown here to
the conditional probability that X takes
on a specific value given that the
random variable Y takes on another
specific value and we use this notation
to indicate those conditional
probabilities as usual the subscripts
indicate the situation that we're
dealing with that is were dealing with a
distribution of the random variable X
and were conditioning on values of the
other random variable Y using the
definition now of conditional
probabilities this can be written as the
probability that both events happen
divided by the probability of the
conditioning event we can turn this
expression into PMF notation and this
leads us to this definition of
conditional pmfs the conditional PMF is
defined to be the ratio of the joint PMF
this is the probability that we have
here by the corresponding marginal PMF
and this is the probability that we have
here now remember that conditional
probabilities are only defined when the
conditioning event has a positive
probability when this denominator is
positive similarly the conditional PMF
will only be defined for those little Y
that have positive probability of
occurring now the conditional PMF is a
function of two arguments little X and
little Y but the best way of thinking
about the conditional PMF
is that we fix the value little why and
then view this expression here as a
function of X as a function of X it
gives us the probabilities of the
different X's that may occur in the
conditional universe and these
probabilities must of course sum to one
again we're keeping Y fixed we live in a
conditional universe where Y takes on a
specific value and here we have the
probabilities of the different X's in
that universe and these sum to one note
that if we change the value of little Y
we will of course get a different
conditional pmf for the random variable
X so what we're really dealing with in
this instance is that we have a family
of conditional pmfs one conditional pmf
for every possible value of little Y and
for every possible value of little Y we
have a legitimate PMF whose values add
to one let us look at an example
consider the joint PMF given in this
table
let us condition on the event that Y is
equal to two which corresponds to this
row in the diagram we have well we need
to know the value of the marginal at
this point so we start by calculating
the probability of y at value two and
this is found by adding the entries in
this row of the table and we find that
this is 5 over 20 then we can start
calculating entries of the conditional
pmf so for example the probability that
X takes on the value of 1 even that Y
takes the value of 2 it is going to be
this entry which is 0 divided by 5 over
20 which gives us 0
we can find the next entry the
probability of X taking the value of 2
given that Y takes the value of 2 will
be this entry 1 over 20 divided by 5
over 20 so it's going to be 1/5 and we
can continue with the other two entries
and we can actually even plot the result
once we are done and what we have is
that at 1 we have a probability of 0 at
2 we have a probability of 1/5 at 3 we
have a probability of 3 over 20 divided
by 5 of over 20 which is 3/5 and at 4 we
have again the probability of 1/5 so
what we have plotted here is the
conditional PMF it's a PMF in the
variable X who are X ranges over the
possible values but where we have fixed
the value of y to be equal to 2 now we
could have found this conditional PMF
even faster without doing any divisions
by following the intuitive argument that
we have used before we live in this
conditional universe we have conditioned
on Y being equal to 2 the conditional
probabilities will have the same
proportions as the original
probabilities except that they need to
be scaled so that they add to 1 so they
should be in the proportions of 0 1 3 1
and 4 these to add to 1 we need to put
everywhere a denominator of 5 so the
proportions are indeed 0 1 3 & 1
pictorially the conditional PMF has the
same form as the corresponding slice of
the joint PMF
except again that the entries of that
slice are renormalized so that the
entries add to one and finally an
observation we can take the definition
of the conditional pmf and turn it
around by moving the denominator to the
other side and obtain a formula which is
a version of the multiplication rule the
probability that X takes a value little
X and Y takes a value little Y is the
product of the probability that Y takes
this particular value times the
conditional probability that X takes on
the particular value little X given that
Y takes on the particular value little Y
we also have a symmetrical relationship
if we interchange the roles of x and y
as we discussed earlier in this course
the multiplication rule can be used to
specify probability models one way of
modeling two random variables is by
specifying the joint PMF but we now have
an alternative indirect way using the
multiplication rule we can first specify
the distribution of Y and then specify
the conditional PMF of X for any given
value of little Y and this completely
determines the joint PMF and so we have
a full probability model we can also
provide similar definitions of
conditional pmfs for the case where
we're dealing with more than two random
variables in this case notation is
pretty self-explanatory by looking at
this expression here you can probably
guess that this stands for the
probability that random variable X takes
on a specific value conditional on the
random variables y and z taking on some
other specific values using the
definition of conditional probabilities
this is the probability that all events
happen the
provided by the probability of the
conditioning event which in our case is
the event that Y takes on a specific
value and simultaneously Z takes and
other specific values in PMF notation
this is the ratio of the joint PMF of
the three random variables together
divided by the joint PMF of the two
random variables Y and Z as another
example we could have an expression like
this which again stands for the
probability that these two random
variables take on specific values
conditional on this random variable
taking on another value finally we can
have versions of the multiplication rule
for the case where we're dealing with
more than two random variables recall
the usual multiplication rule for three
events happening simultaneously let us
apply this multiplication rule for the
case where the event a stands for the
event that the random variable X takes
on a specific value let B be the event
that Y takes on a specific value and C
be the event that random variable Z
takes on a specific value then we can
take this relation the multiplication
rule and translate it into PMF notation
the probability that all three events
happen is equal to the product of the
probability that the first event happens
then we have the conditional probability
that the second event happens given that
the first happened times the conditional
probability that the third event happens
this one given that the first two events
have happened